okay for nothing else you should watch
this movie for the opening tracking shot
I'm just saying I saw the opening track
and shot I was like this is gonna be the
best James Bond movie ever whether or
not it is guess is what we're gonna talk
about here Spectre suspect her is the
newest James Bond movie the newest James
Bond movie with Daniel Craig as the lead
character James Bond picks up not long
after Skyfall James Bond's kind of going
off the books and he has his mission he
wants to accomplish and back home mi6 is
ultimately dealing with everything the
crew had to deal with the Mission
Impossible rogue nation seriously it's
the exact same thing but James Bond
search leads him to the super shady
shadow organization called Spectre
alright there are things to like about
this movie for sure if you missed my
opening statement in this video go back
and watch it because this movie is
supremely shot seriously from the get-go
I was like screw the best James Bond
movie ever it is one of the most well
shot James Bond movies ever action
scenes were well shot you weren't
confused it wasn't doing that weird
shaky-cam [ __ ] too much it was exciting
it was suspenseful it was dirty I mean
there's something about these James Bond
movies from Casino Royale on except
Quantum of Solace the fights are just
gritty and people are going through
tables going through walls the sound
effects really bring you into it when
bottles crack over people's heads you
feel it you're like that glass shattered
and hurt cause a concussion I loved the
action in these movies and Daniel Craig
is great as James Bond once again this
dude is showing us why he's one of the
best James Bond's ever I like the girl
also there's this girl in this movie
they tried too hard to make her the one
like oh maybe James Bond could really
love this girl I don't really buy that
too much she has a solid Bond girl the
one she had to look to she was good
actress 3 she knew had to shoot like she
could throw down if you really needed to
this movie had quite a few trip up first
of all you have Christoph Waltz as the
main villain that should be a home run
right there really not not when he isn't
great when he's on screen for all three
scenes he's on screen in this movie
that's three scenes folks you know these
James Bond movies they're not short or
deals those movies going on and on and
on you're like come on let's meet the
villain come on let's meet the villain
you finally meet him it's a great scene
you always all shadowy you saw it in the
trailer you know he's all blacked out
you don't really know who he is super
villain status right there alright let's
not see this guy for a long time again
I'm just really
boy how they handled the villain in this
movie a movie like this needs a great
villain you look at Silva in the last
one he was awesome you hear about how
terrible he is at first and then you
finally meet him and he has this great
introduction whereas he's just walking
towards James Bond giving a monologue
about rat he was smart but he did [ __ ]
he got it done he did some terrible
stuff in Skyfall
I feel like Christoph Waltz more or less
talked about how awesome he has been in
his life
we have messed with your life so much in
the past they go through such lengths to
beat over your head how awesome this guy
has been in the past without actually
showing you enough of that in the
president kind of reminds me of that
pathetic 40 year old who still wears his
Letterman's jacket talking about the
good old days it's like yeah I get it
just show me stuff now that it only
really infuriates me that the completely
wasted the villain in this movie because
the paper trail and the breadcrumbs that
James Bond is following trying to find
this organization it's not that
interesting some great action sequences
sprinkled in there for sure but when
he's actually just on the hunt you're
like all right it's basic spy stuff with
a great villain you could have still
brought it home made it a great Bond
movies like alright the paper trail yeah
but that villain was awesome it partly
has to do with this subplot that is
completely Mission Impossible rogue
nation the thing where the government's
trying to annex the double-o program
into them because they're like that's an
obsolete format as the whole information
is the New Age and Big Brother's gonna
watch and that's how we're gonna keep a
handle on things every scene that has to
do with that you could have just
concentrated on Spectre more in the
villain there you can add more
villainous development but the movie
really never actually goes there and as
much as this movie looks like it's gonna
be a personal journey of discovery for
James Bond it is in a sense not as much
as it could have been it's like ooh this
deep person alright moving on whoa what
you're not even gonna constant you just
gonna breeze by that alright guys in the
end there was enough to enjoy inspector
Daniel Craig shows us why he still has
the part although allegedly is his last
one the action was fantastic it was
exciting it was an interesting enough
movie but when I was watching I was like
would I care as much if it wasn't a
James Bond movie I don't know that I
would have James Bond the character and
the universe it's gotten us you know
that's what brings us into it and that's
what makes us tolerate sloppy writing
more still a fun enough movie not as
good as Casino Royale or Skyfall loads
better than Quantum of Solace I'll say
Spectre is a good time no alcohol
required alright guys so your fav
James Bond villain who is it whoever it
is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more